un dernier vol rio paris avant une date
encore indéfinie pour limiter la
propagation du variant brésilien p1 et
de ses mutations
les liaisons aériennes entre la france
et le brésil sont désormais suspendus
jusqu'à nouvel ordre
réclamé par l'opposition cette décision
a été annoncée ce mardi après midi par
jean castex lors des questions au
gouvernement à l'assemblée nationale
nous constatons que la situation
s'aggrave et nous avons donc décidé de
suspendre jusqu'à nouvel ordre tous les
vols entre le brésil et la france
ce lundi le gouvernement avait pourtant
écarté la possibilité de stopper des
liaisons aériennes
invité sur lci le ministre délégué aux
transports jean baptiste djebbari assuré
que le bon fonctionnement des vols
étaient imposées par le conseil d'état
une déclaration qui n'a pas manqué
d'être rappelé par certains membres de
l'opposition
je me réjouis de la décision du premier
ministre de suspendre les vols entre la
france et le brésil
il faut maintenant aller plus loin en
suspens dans l'ensemble des vols émanant
de zones à risque notre pays et les
français ne supporteraient pas une
nouvelle vague dévastatrice
poussé dans ses retranchements par mon
collègue patrick hetzel
le premier ministre annonce à l'instant
en réponse à sa question d'actualité que
le gouvernement suspend les vols en
provenance du brésil
nous avions donc bien raison de le
réclamer il était temps hier le maintien
des lignes aériennes avec le brésil
était imposé par le droit selon le
ministre des transports aujourd'hui
elles sont suspendues ce gouvernement
ment du matin au soir sur ce sujet et
tout le reste
depuis le 3 mars dernier le brésil
recense plus de mille morts par jour
avec un pic à 4239 décès en 24 heures le
8 avril
la situation sanitaire ne cesse de
s'empirer dans le plus grand pays
d'amérique latine
la faute aux vaillants p1 et à ces
dizaines de mutation qui rendent la
situation incontrôlable sur le
territoire brésilien
ce mardi les parisiens semblaient plutôt
rassurés par la suspension des vols
entre les deux pays
plus la situation actuelle au brésil qui
est assez catastrophique
cc il y avait possibilité de par
importer sa virus chez nous ce serait
pas mal
wii fit mon corps est chacun chez soi
pourra essayer déjà de d'améliorer cette
pandémie quelle soit pas trop prise
d'assaut je pense qu'il fallait fermer
ses frontières avant je pense après
je sais pas c'est trop tard mais on
verra après je pense d'ici deux semaines
si on nous ici en tous les cas on
retrouve des variantes brésilien voilà
je pense que c'est une bonne chose
bah il faut limiter les mails
il mélange le brassage des populations
si la france interrompt ses vols jusqu'à
nouvel ordre avec le brésil
quid des liaisons avec la guyane dans ce
département d'outre-mer français le
variant brésilien représentait plus de
80% des cas positifs recensés la semaine
dernière pour autant les liaisons
aériennes ne sont pas interrompues pour
le moment
des avions en provenance de cayenne
atterrissent chaque jour à l'aéroport de
paris-orly